MALE SPEAKER: Sorry for
the delays, everyone.
Assif, the very good
boyfriend that he was,
was not willing to leave
his girlfriend stranded
on Google campus.
AASIF MANDVI:
Apparently, you guys
have figured out
everything except parking.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
AASIF MANDVI: Which I think
is the next great Google
enterprise, how to get
parking on this campus.
How are you guys?
Everybody good?
Great.
Well, thank you for coming out.
MALE SPEAKER: Definitely.
AASIF MANDVI:
Thank you for this.
And my book's on sale over
there, for some reason,
incredibly cheap.
I don't know why.
Much cheaper than it is in
real life, so get it now.
MALE SPEAKER:
Subsidized for Google.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes, exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: So here we are in
conversation with Assif Mandvi.
I take it, many of you are
familiar with his work.
We're going to talk a little
bit about your book, "No Man's
Land" today.
AASIF MANDVI: "No Land's Man."
MALE SPEAKER: "No Land's Man."
AASIF MANDVI: Starting
off really well.
Thank you very much, with
the wrong name of the book.
MALE SPEAKER: These notes are
not even worth their weight.
AASIF MANDVI: No,
"No Land's Man."
It's a play on no man's land.
It's called, "No Land's Man."
So you flip it, and that's
how I came up with this title.
And now everyone gets it wrong.
MALE SPEAKER: And now, none
of you will ever forget.
AASIF MANDVI: "No Land's Man."
MALE SPEAKER: Land's man.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: And well, what
did you mean by that title?
AASIF MANDVI: I meant
that I've grown up
in many different places.
I was born in India,
grew up in the UK,
and then spent my high
school and college years
in Florida and then New York.
And so for me, it encapsulated
that immigrant journey,
that immigrant experience of
living in different places,
having to be a constant.
I think a lot of what
I've done is involve shape
shifting and adapting
to environments,
different environments.
It's probably why I became
an actor, on some level.
But that's what
the title is about.
MALE SPEAKER: Mhm.
AASIF MANDVI: Should
I be looking at you,
or should I be
looking at the camera?
Because this is going live
streaming right now, right?
MALE SPEAKER: This is
going live streaming.
AASIF MANDVI: I can do either?
I can go back and forth?
MALE SPEAKER: You want to
deliver something, just
deadpan.
AASIF MANDVI: Great.
I can just do that.
OK, so it's like
"The Daily Show."
I'm talking to you, but then I'm
talking to the people at home.
MALE SPEAKER: We
break the third wall.
I appreciate that.
No, it's an interesting title.
What were you
hoping to accomplish
by writing this book?
AASIF MANDVI: I was
hoping to accomplish
getting a really large amount
of money to write the book.
No, I wrote it because
Chronicle Books
approached me to write a book.
And they said, would you be
interested in writing a book?
And I had already been
writing monologues, essays,
short pieces.
And everything I write pretty
much has to do with my life,
because I'm incredibly
interesting.
And so I just decided, oh,
this would be a great venue.
I haven't actually ever
written a book before.
I've written plays,
I've written movies.
But to write a book
felt like a challenge
that I hadn't taken on.
And it was an incredibly
fulfilling, hard, lonely
experience.
But I'm very proud of it.
And I feel like I got
to tell a lot of stories
about things that happened not
just about me, but on a larger,
cultural context,
hopefully saying something
about the immigrant experience.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
No, it's interesting
that you got
asked to write the book in that
I think most authors don't have
that liberty of
just saying, hey,
I'm sure you have
something to say.
AASIF MANDVI: Right.
Well, I think it had
to do with the fact
that I was in a little show
called, "The Daily Show."
MALE SPEAKER: Probably helped.
AASIF MANDVI: And
I think they were
like-- everybody on "The
Daily Show" writes a book,
and so you should
also write a book.
No, clearly there
was a public platform
there that I think
they felt like maybe I
had something to say,
which I hope I did.
MALE SPEAKER: But it wasn't
really like a treatise
that you would expect some
"Daily Show" author to come off
their political
pedestal and tell you
how politics should be done.
It was a series of
vignettes about your life
and these kind of short stories.
Almost Sedaris-like,
in some sense.
I hope you take that
as a compliment.
AASIF MANDVI: I do.
I'm a huge David Sedaris fan,
and to be compared to him
in any way at all is
a huge compliment.
But that's what I
wanted to write.
I came from a
theatrical background
doing theater, and going
to drama school, and all
that stuff.
So for me, the personal
is the political.
And all stories-- the
best stories are personal.
And the greatest plays
and the greatest movies
all have to do with
some form of family.
And so that is what I attempted
to do in this book, which
is really talk about my
journey, talk about my family,
talk about that, and hopefully,
resonate on a larger level.
MALE SPEAKER: Mhm.
Was there a style
you were trying
to emulate with the
structure you went after?
Or is this just how it came out?
AASIF MANDVI: Maybe
Peter Benchley's "Jaws."
But I think I failed
miserably in that.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think I sensed that.
AASIF MANDVI: It
was a whole story
about how I got
attacked by a shark
that I took out because
it was completely made up.
No, I guess people
like Sedaris--
I really just wanted-- I had
written a play years ago,
a one-man-show called,
"Sakina's Restaurant," which
was a series of also vignettes,
but done in a monologue
performance style.
And I wanted to take that
and turn it into a narrative,
into a book form,
into a prose thing.
But it's dealing
with the same subject
matter and the
same general world,
but just different stories.
So I really was writing
the way I write.
And so hopefully, people
will like it and enjoy it.
MALE SPEAKER: I
thoroughly enjoyed it.
I promise we'll get to the
content in just a moment.
AASIF MANDVI: You don't
have to, it's fine.
I'm totally happy
to sit here and talk
about other people's books.
MALE SPEAKER: Just the structure
of the book, if we could
[INAUDIBLE].
AASIF MANDVI: "Great Gatsby,"
it's a terrific book,
if you haven't read it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
MALE SPEAKER: No, actually,
it was interesting.
It doesn't read like
an autobiography.
AASIF MANDVI: No.
MALE SPEAKER: It really
has a sense of sequence,
but also a sense of
just trains of thought.
I just found it
wonderful to read.
It was an absolute pleasure.
AASIF MANDVI: Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I cringe at the
word, "biography"
or "memoir," or
whatever, because I
don't think of it that way.
I also don't feel like
I'm at a place in life
where I'm like, (OLD, CROAKY
VOICE) I'm writing my memoir.
I just feel like they are
stories inspired by my life.
And they're entertaining,
and humorous, and sometimes
a little bit sad.
So I think they're just
vignettes and little snapshots
of things in a person's
life that hopefully we
can relate to.
And I deal with some real
issues of race, and religion,
and stuff like that as
seen through the eyes
of a little brown kid
living in a white world.
So you can relate, right pal?
Yes.
Indians in the
front are like, yes,
brown people in the white world.
Yes, we know.
MALE SPEAKER: Brown
people in a white world.
But also, one that doesn't
necessarily relate to--
AASIF MANDVI: Although
here, it's sort
of white people in a
brown world, isn't it?
I mean in Google, kind
of a reverse thing there.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Race, religion, identity--
these are all definitely
very prevalent
topics in the book.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So
were these things
that you were working out
as you were writing them?
Or did you have something
to say about them,
and you wanted to find the
right stories that captured it?
AASIF MANDVI: It was a
combination of things.
I started off wanting
to say something,
and then realized I
actually had something else
that I was saying, and
then went down that.
It sounds really,
(OLD, CROAKY VOICE)
I discovered a great deal about
myself as I wrote this book.
But that's what happens
when you write stories
about yourself, and your life,
and things that have happened
to you that you hopefully
gain a level of insight.
Otherwise, why the fuck
are you writing it?
Because then, you can share
that insight with others,
and hopefully they gain a level
of insight into their life.
And that's how art works.
MALE SPEAKER: Mm.
AASIF MANDVI: That's
how art works.
And that is one to grow on.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you have any
specific examples of things
that you learned?
Things where you wrote it, and
you were like, oh, yeah, that
was profound.
In those words.
AASIF MANDVI: I
think it's dangerous
whenever a writer is sitting in
front of his computer writing
and then stops and goes, yes.
Now, that is profound.
Most of my experience of
writing was more like,
what the hell am I doing?
Why am I sitting here
writing this thing?
No one cares, that
kind of stuff.
But yes, there were
definitely specific things
where in talking about my
immigrant journey from the UK,
to the US, and the transitions
that happened there,
and coming to New York
as a young actor trying
to get work and then even
on "The Daily Show," talking
about the experience of being
on "The Daily Show," as,
at the time when I
started, which was in 2006,
and W was still president.
And we were very much
entrenched in this war.
And oh, wait-- it
sounds like today.
But you know what I mean?
So definitely,
there were insights
that came out as I wrote that.
Hopefully, that is what
happens when you write.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
It was interesting to hear
first person perspective.
You struggle with
so many concepts
about, especially
religion, feeling
like your skin is
labeled like a Muslim.
But you don't really have that.
But your parents are that,
and yet you connect with it.
AASIF MANDVI: Right.
MALE SPEAKER: A lot
of back and forth.
AASIF MANDVI: Yeah.
I definitely tried to be honest
about my personal relationship
with my struggles with Islam.
I say in the book that
I've been in more bars
than mosques over the
course of my life,
and I'm no representation
of a Muslim, by any means.
But yet, I somehow got hired as
the senior Muslim correspondent
on "The Daily Show," to which
my parents were completely
flummoxed.
They were like, why
would he hire you?
You don't even know
how to do salaam.
But that is the outside versus
the inside, and who you end up
being, and sort of the
shapes that you end up
taking in order to be
accepted, especially as a kid.
I grew up in
England in the '70s,
and there was a lot of racism.
And I went to a boarding school.
And I dealt with
the racial stuff
that was going on there, and the
class stuff, and all of that.
And then I talk about the
different-- like in the UK,
it doesn't matter how
long you've been there.
As a kid growing up in the UK,
as an immigrant, Indian parents
in England, it doesn't matter
how long you've been there.
I felt like you always
were a foreigner.
You would always feel that
sense of being a foreigner.
And in America, it was the
opposite which is true,
which was that you
arrive in America.
And people are just
like, ah, we're
the thousand years of culture
and history and religions.
But forget that,
you're an American now.
Pledge of Allegiance to the
flag, you're an American.
In fact, we're going
to put American
before we say who you are.
So you are now an
American, Indian America.
But the thing here,
I found, was that
because-- whoa, what's going on?
Yeah, we're doing an
interview here, pal.
MALE SPEAKER: [LAUGHING]
AASIF MANDVI: Of
course they're Indian.
(INDIAN ACCENT) What
is going on here?
Is there free food?
Oh, there's free
food everywhere!
It's OK.
That's why there's
so many Indians here,
because you have free food.
What was I saying?
MALE SPEAKER: I think
about struggles,
and religion, and so forth.
AASIF MANDVI: Anyway, yes.
When you come to America,
there's that sense of,
you just get absorbed
into this Americana.
There's a line in
my book actually,
when I say Americans think about
the rest of the world the way
New Yorkers think about
the rest of America.
Which is, they don't.
MALE SPEAKER: You talk a lot
about your acting influences
going back to childhood.
AASIF MANDVI: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: You talk about
being inspired by Omar Sharif.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you talk
about why he inspires you,
and what that did
to your career?
AASIF MANDVI: Well, Omar
Sharif was, at that time,
before we had Aziz Ansari,
we had Omar Sharif.
And Omar Sharif was
the first brown face
that I saw in a Hollywood movie.
And so for me, as a
little kid, watching that,
my heroes were the
Fonz, or whatever.
And I would watch
American television shows,
and I would want
to try to be that.
And I liked the Fonz, because
his real name was Fonzarelli,
and my name was
Mandviwala and I figured,
we both had really dorky names.
And yet, he seemed to
have transcended that,
and become really cool.
So I thought there
was hope for me.
But then I saw Omar Sharif.
And I remember
that sense of, oh.
Here's the first brown person.
And I was taken aback.
And so there was a weird
hope in terms of, oh.
There's a possibility
of actually
being an actor in
Hollywood, or being
an actor, if you're
a brown person.
Because I didn't really
grow up with Bollywood
and all the Indian actors.
All of my acting heroes
were Caucasian men.
So he was the first that wasn't.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, and fast
forward to recent time--
really with this, now, it
sounds like you actually
inspired quite a few various
types brown Americans,
Muslim Americans, Indian
descent, whatever.
And so it's almost as if
you've, to some degree,
come most of the full circle.
Do you feel like this book is
a bit of an homage to that,
hoping to inspire other
young Aasifs out there?
AASIF MANDVI: That's a
tough question to answer,
because you never really feel
like you've come full circle.
You just end up feeling you're
somewhere on the treadmill
trying to figure it out.
But yes, I am
always proud when I
feel like there are
younger South Asian
writers, performers, whatever,
who have been inspired by what
I've done, or have read
my work, or whatever.
So yes.
When I wrote,
"Sakina's Restaurant,"
I grew up-- so as a young
actor, you go to auditions,
and you would have to do
a monologue, and whatever.
And I would always
have to do something
from like, "Death
of a Salesman,"
because there were no plays
written for brown characters.
There were no parts.
And so when I wrote
"Sakina's Restaurant," one
of the personally
most fulfilling
moments was that
because I created
these characters
for brown actors--
because there were
brown, Indian characters,
a kid came up to me one time
and said, I got into grad school
using one of your monologues
from "Sakina's Restaurant."
Which was pretty cool for me.
Outside of everything
else, that was really cool.
Because I was like, oh.
You actually had a character
that you could personally
relate to instead of doing Biff.
You could do this
brown, Indian character,
and actually get into
grad school with it.
So yes, that feels good.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Actually, so you
said, there were
no roles written
for brown people.
But on a much more
depressing level,
and one that you've
written on, there
were plenty of roles
written for brown people
given to white people.
AASIF MANDVI: Right.
MALE SPEAKER: And you called
it-- "whitewashing," I guess,
is a term probably
used in Hollywood more.
AASIF MANDVI: Yeah,
there were, yes.
It's happened across- it's
not just brown people,
but anybody who
was not Caucasian
was often, in early
Hollywood, especially,
Mickey Rooney in "Breakfast
at Tiffany's," of course,
is the most famous case of
whitewashing that there is.
But even in the '80s,
you had Fisher Stevens
playing an Indian guy in "Short
Circuit," and stuff like that.
So when they actually started
to hire Kal Penn, it was cool.
When "Harold and Kumar" came
along, it was like, oh, OK.
Now, we see a brown
guy and an Asian guy
in the leads in a film.
So things have
changed since when
I was auditioning to be a snake
charmer for a commercial, which
they ended up
casting a white guy.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
you refer to that
in the book as potanking.
AASIF MANDVI: Potanking.
So potanking is a word that my
good friend, Sakina Jaffrey,
who you might all know
from "The House of Cards."
Oh, there's whole bunch
of people over here.
I have not even
been looking at you.
Hi , how are you?
AUDIENCE: Good, how are you?
AASIF MANDVI: Nice to see you.
So she came up with this term.
And we used to
use this term when
we were actors in New York.
And it was potanking,
which is basically
when they want you to embody
the Indian stereotype.
And what it sounds like to
them is, (INDIAN ACCENT)
potank, potank, potank,
potank, potank, potank, potank.
So when we would
go to auditions,
she would always say
to me, how'd it go?
And I'd be like, great.
And she's like, did
they have you potank?
And I would be
like, yes, they did.
Because they invariably
were always like,
could you do-- nobody
knew that's what
it was called except us.
But that was our inside
beltway slang for it.
MALE SPEAKER: Although when
you look back, certainly,
the more notable
things you've done.
I don't feel like you had
to put on that accent.
So do you feel like
you've been able to grow
through that as an actor?
Or do you still feel like you're
faced with this constantly?
AASIF MANDVI: Well, no, I
am faced with this still,
to this day.
And luckily, I have a little bit
more leverage now than I did.
In fact, talking of when
I did "The Internship,"
I had to do the Indian accent.
And they wanted the character
to have an Indian accent.
And I remember going
in and auditioning,
and meeting with Vince Vaughn
and Shawn Levy, the director,
who were very great.
But then I got a call from one
of the producers of the film
saying that Warner
Brothers would
like to hire a dialect coach
for you for the Indian accent.
And I said, they know
that I am Indian, right,
and I have Indian parents.
And they were like, no, no, no.
They know.
But they felt like
your accent was not
as strong as the other
actors that were coming in.
And I was like, I know.
That was for a reason.
And so I had to push
back a little bit
and be like, this
guy, I'm not going
to do him as some stereotype
of an Indian accent.
So I actually modulated
the Indian accent
so that they wanted the
accent, but I gave them
my version of what that was.
And I remember saying
to them, do you
know the way Fareed
Zakaria sounds?
And they were like, yes, we do.
And they're like, that's
the accent I'm going to do.
And they were like, we
love Fareed Zakaria.
We think he's great.
I was like, there you go.
That's it.
That's not Apu,
it's Fareed Zakaria.
MALE SPEAKER: Nice.
AASIF MANDVI: Fareed is watching
this right now, (MOCKING FAREED
ZAKARIA) He doesn't
sound like me at all.
MALE SPEAKER: [LAUGHING]
AASIF MANDVI: (FALSETTO)
Do I sound like the guy
from "The Internship?"
MALE SPEAKER: That's hilarious.
AASIF MANDVI: I don't know why
I just gave him Stewie's voice.
(IMPERSONATING STEWIE FROM
"FAMILY GUY") I say-- Go ahead.
MALE SPEAKER: You were
raised in England.
It's an interesting
background, because I
don't think anybody
would have guessed that.
AASIF MANDVI: It's
a well kept secret.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, your accent
doesn't tell that at all.
AASIF MANDVI: Right.
It's funny.
Sometimes people
hear it-- I feel
like I have one of those
accents where sometimes, people
are like, once I tell them
I was raised in England,
then they're like, oh yeah.
I totally hear it.
And I'm like, no, you don't.
You think you do now,
because I just told you that.
But I grew up in the
north of England.
So I had a very thick Northern
accent, like that, really--
[GRUMBLING]
(NORTHERN BRITISH ACCENT)
Right, where are you going?
Oh yeah, great.
Like I sound like that.
And imagine if I
sounded like that now.
But I think, again, going back
to the whole idea of adapting
to various, different
environments,
I think I got to
Florida and realized
that nobody knew what
I was talking about.
And when I was
living in Florida,
the combination of a
northern, British accent
with an American
accent ended up making
me sound like I
was from Brooklyn.
And so people thought
I was from Brooklyn
when I lived in Florida.
I'd never even
lived in Brooklyn.
And so it was
really interesting,
because the way it
melded together.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you didn't just
move to Florida,
you moved to Tampa, Florida.
AASIF MANDVI: Tampa, Florida.
MALE SPEAKER: It's the gem.
AASIF MANDVI: Which is
the armpit of Florida.
No, I'm kidding, Tampa.
Love you, love you.
No, it was great.
That was America to me
when I got to Tampa.
I was like, America's
full of strip clubs,
really awesome
strip clubs-- like,
the best strip clubs in-- no.
And Chik-fil-A's.
It's Chik-fil-A's
and strip clubs.
But that was America, Florida.
I think I thought my life
would be like I'd just
be hanging out with a
dolphin all the time,
and living on a sailboat.
But I ended up in the
suburbs of Tampa, Florida.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AASIF MANDVI: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Some of the
stories were fish out of water
to some degree.
But also, you embracing
it much more--
or rather, your father embracing
Americanism to a degree.
AASIF MANDVI: Right.
You're talking about
brunch, aren't you?
MALE SPEAKER: I
am, a little bit.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes.
My dad, when he first came
to Florida, he called us.
We were in England, and he came
out on a reconnaissance mission
to see if he wanted to
move the family to Florida.
And he called us,
and he was like, they
have this wonderful thing here.
It is called, "brunch."
It is breakfast and lunch.
They have a third meal, brunch.
He thought it was
an in-between meal.
He was like, there's
breakfast, then there's brunch,
then there's lunch.
And I was like, I don't
think that's what it is.
I googled it.
No, I didn't.
There was no Google back then.
People had dictionaries.
He was obsessed with this
idea of this brunch thing.
So I remember, that was one
of my first-- hello, hello.
How are you?
They're just on
their way to class.
So it was one of these
first memories of America,
was coming to America and then
going to get brunch at IHOP,
or wherever.
So I have a story
about that actually,
in my book, about how my
father was obsessed with that.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
and he also addresses
what he thinks to be the golden
rule of American consumption,
which is like, eat
as much as you can.
AASIF MANDVI: Eat
Eat it all!
Because look, the idea that
America is the land of plenty.
For him, he took that literally.
And he was like, let's go to
Albertson's and take pictures
of huge jars of peanut butter
and send them back to India
to make them jealous.
I don't know.
But he definitely
embraced American culture
with open arms
and an open mouth.
MALE SPEAKER: You also
wrote about your experience
and your first star or lead
role with "The Mystic Masseur."
AASIF MANDVI: Yes,
"The Mystic Masseur."
MALE SPEAKER: What did you
learn from this experience?
What did that take away?
AASIF MANDVI: Again, when I
was doing "Sakina's Restaurant"
off-Broadway, which is the
one man show that I wrote,
a gentleman by the name of
Ismail Merchant approached me.
And Ismael Merchant, for those
of you who might not know,
was the merchant
in Merchant Ivory.
And they made all these amazing
movies back in the '80s,
like "Remains of the
Day," and "Howards End,"
and "Room With a View," and
won a lot of Academy Awards.
And they created an entire
genre of films, period films.
And so Ismael came up to me
after the play and was like,
I've got a movie that I'm making
based on V.S. Naipaul's book,
"The Mystic Masseur,"
and I'd like
you to play the
lead in this film.
And so it was a tremendous
opportunity as a young actor.
I'd had like, two lines on
"Law & Order," at that time.
So it was great.
But it was nervewracking
and terrifying.
And he was a Barnum
& Bailey type
character, like
larger than life.
I remember one time--
well, when I first met him,
he took me to this restaurant
that he claimed that he owned,
but none of the waiters
knew who he was.
But he was like,
(INDIAN ACCENT) I
love-- this is a
wonderful restaurant.
I own this.
And then we had this meal,
and he gave me the book.
And then he said, you must
read this book immediately.
We are making the film.
And it's going to be terrific,
and blah, blah, blah.
And then I didn't hear
from him for a year.
And then, like a year
later, he called me.
And he was like, you
have to go to London
for a costume fitting.
And I was like, what?
I don't even know if
I'm doing this movie.
I haven't talked
to you in a year.
He was like, of
course we're doing it!
And he really offended.
And so he was like, of course!
Why would I-- and I was like,
because it was a year ago.
And so then he
flew me to London.
But the crazy thing
was, he was literally
one of the cheapest people.
The man has passed on now.
And God bless him,
and I loved him.
And he was like a crazy uncle
to me, and gave me this amaze--
but he was one of the
cheapest people in the world.
Anthony Hopkins once
said that Ismail Merchant
will steal the cream out of your
coffee if you don't watch out.
And he sent me to London
for a costume fitting,
and he refused to give me
what's called "per diem."
So per diem is basically food
money to eat, and take cabs,
and whatever.
So I was going to be in
London for the weekend,
and he wouldn't give me lodging.
He wouldn't give me a hotel.
He was basically like,
you'll stay in my flat.
And then my manager
at the time was
like, you have to give
him some money to eat.
And so he got frustrated
and called me over
to the Merchant Ivory offices on
57th Street, where I walked in.
I walk into this room where
there's BAFTA's, and Oscars,
and pictures of him with
Anthony Hopkins and Hugh Grant
everywhere on the
walls, and stuff.
And he's screaming
at James Ivory,
who was the other part
of Merchant Ivory,
about how Harvey Weinstein
is an uncouth pig.
Which, you know.
He's not the first or
the last to say that.
But he was screaming about this.
And then I sat there
for about 10 minutes
while he was on the phone.
And then he finally looked up.
And he said, OK.
Your manager is
telling me that you
have to have money to eat
when you are in London.
So here's what I'm going to do.
So he takes out
a piece of paper.
And he writes on it,
dear Mr. Khan-- oh no.
He says to me, he goes, there's
a wonderful Indian restaurant
down the street from my flat.
And he writes, dear
Mr. Khan, please
let my friend, Aasif
Mandvi, eat whatever
he would like on the menu when
he comes to your establishment.
Signed, your friend,
Ismail Merchant.
And he rolls it up,
puts it in an envelope.
Gives it to me, and says, you
go to this Indian restaurant.
He will give you whatever
food you require.
That means I literally only
had to eat Indian food.
And then he's like, but when
the bill comes, remember,
he's supposed to
give me 50% off.
So he wanted a 50%
discount on this free food.
So that was him.
But he was crazy.
And then he accused me of having
sex on his chair when I was--
house was like the inside
of Sotheby's or Christie's.
Everything was from
Rajasthan from the 1600s.
He had the raj, and he had
these antique chairs, I guess.
And they were in his dining
room, and I sat on them.
And they broke because
I was leaning back,
because the TV was
in his dining room.
So I break the chair.
He has a dinner party.
Some woman sits on the chair, it
breaks because I had broken it.
And I tried to put it
back together with glue.
And then he proceeds to
tell the entire dinner party
that me, his guest,
had been having
sex on his antique
chairs and broken them.
And I'm standing there.
And everyone looking at me,
like why would you do that?
That's a terribly
impolite thing to do.
And I'm like, what?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, you've
mentioned "Sakina's Restaurant"
a couple of times.
I do want to talk about that.
Because it really only
showed in New York,
or maybe in New
York and Chicago.
AASIF MANDVI: Well, actually,
we played in a couple of places.
We played in New
York, and then we
toured it around a little bit.
We brought it to LA.
We took it to London, to
the Bush theater in London.
And for a couple years, I was
touring around with that show.
But when we did an
off-Broadway in New York,
it was the first play about
a South Asian family written
by a South Asian that was done
on the mainstream New York
stage.
And so we got quite a
bit of attention just
from that perspective.
And then we made it into a
film called, "Today's Special,"
which is available on Netflix.
And it was good.
It was good to do.
MALE SPEAKER: So your roots
are really in dramatic acting.
AASIF MANDVI: Really, yeah.
I went to drama school.
The whole "Daily Show" thing
came out of left field,
and has changed my
life, and has been
a tremendous opportunity for me.
But my love is really
theater, in the same way
that John Oliver goes back
to do standup in the clubs
where he grew up.
I grew up doing theater.
And also, in drama
school, you don't
think of comedy
versus-- in Hollywood,
they're like, you can
do comedy and drama?
What?
They're amazed by that.
But in drama school,
you do it all.
You're doing
Chekhov and Moliere.
MALE SPEAKER: Mhm.
AASIF MANDVI: A little
Chekhov, Moliere drop, boom!
MALE SPEAKER: So how
prepared were you
for this "Daily
Show" opportunity?
I couldn't get the
sense of how much
standup or comedy experience.
AASIF MANDVI: I had
comedy experience.
I'd been in a
sketch comedy group.
I hadn't really done standup,
but I'd done more improv,
sketch stuff.
And when "The Daily Show" came
along, the great thing for me
was specifically, John was
not looking for a comedian.
Because I think they often go
scout comedy clubs or places
like that.
He was looking for an actor.
And so when I came in to
audition for "The Daily Show,"
it really was for
a one-off gig where
they had written this Middle
East correspondent character
and realized, oh.
We don't have a Middle
East correspondent.
So they had to audition people.
So I came in, auditioned,
and he actually
offered me the job that day.
Like I basically
came in and was like,
I don't know what
I'm doing here.
I'm just going to do my best
Stephen Colbert impression.
And so I did this impression
of Stephen Colbert.
Jon turned to me, said,
welcome to "The Daily Show."
And I was on that night.
And the weird thing
was that I went out--
it was the weirdest
day of my life.
So I walk out onto the
stage at the rehearsal.
Because we usually rehearse
around 4 o'clock, and then
we tape at like 6:00.
And at 4 o'clock,
I go out there.
And usually, in the
audience, there's
a few producers, and some
of the writers, and stuff.
And everything's changing,
and they're writing.
So I go out there
for this rehearsal,
and I look out in the audience.
And there's a guy sitting
there with a baseball cap.
And he's just hanging out.
And I'm looking at him.
And I look a little
bit more closely.
And it turns out that
it's Bruce Springsteen.
And of course, my first
reaction is, holy God,
Bruce Springsteen works
at "The Daily Show!"
But he didn't work
at "The Daily Show."
He was just visiting.
And so then I do the show,
and then Bruce Springsteen
comes back.
So not only did I meet
Jon Stewart the first time
and was on "The Daily
Show," I also met
The Boss who came backstage, and
told me that I was very funny.
And I him, you're
a very good singer.
You're good at singing.
What can I say?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, you
mentioned that they hired you,
and you were on that night.
I was going to ask, is that
protocol for "The Daily Show?"
AASIF MANDVI: No.
I think I'm the
only person that's
ever been hired that way.
Because I was
hired as a one-off.
It was just going to
be for that one night.
And then Jon, god
bless him, kept
calling me back and
just saying, hey.
You want to come back and
hang out and do another piece,
and whatever?
And so I just kept coming back.
And eventually, after about four
months, what I realized was,
that was my audition period.
That was my trial.
And then after four months,
they offered me a contract.
And then I was there until now.
MALE SPEAKER: So I
was going to ask.
I've had a fantastic run there.
I know that correspondents come
in and out of "The Daily Show."
AASIF MANDVI: I've actually
been away from "The Daily
Show" for the last six
months because I've
been doing an HBO series called,
"The Brink," which comes out
next year with Jack
Black and Tim Robbins,
and a whole bunch of
really great actors.
And it's a half
hour comedy staying
in the geopolitical
satire world.
But it's a half hour comedy
about the end of the world.
Not specifically the
end of the world,
but like a huge global crisis.
So if "24" or
"Homeland" was a comedy,
this is what it would be.
So it's great.
And I'm very excited
about it, and HBO's
very excited about it.
It comes out next year.
So I've actually been away
from "The Daily Show."
So I've actually now am more
part time on "The Daily Show."
I gave up my office.
And now, I'm just going to
job in whenever they need me,
or whatever I'm free.
MALE SPEAKER: So now
there's an open role
for Senior Muslim Correspondent.
AASIF MANDVI: It is.
It's great.
And again, Jon has been the
greatest boss, because he's
let me go off and do
movies and other things,
and then come back
and always have a home
at "The Daily Show."
And so this one,
he was like, look.
You're going to be
gone for six months.
Why don't you just-- because
it always feels like I
go off and do other stuff.
And he was like, rather
than that, why don't we
just have you come in
whenever you need to come in
and do stuff?
So you'll still
see me on the show,
I just probably won't be
there on a full time basis.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
Yeah.
You've had some pretty
great correspondent
names, as they are good at it.
My favorite is probably Senior
Foreign-Looking Correspondent.
AASIF MANDVI: Looking
Correspondent, yes.
That's my favorite too.
MALE SPEAKER: You said you
started out as Stephen Colbert.
I've got to imagine, you
really molded this role
into something.
So when did you envision
yourself on "The Daily Show?"
AASIF MANDVI: I never did.
This is a tough question.
Because other people,
I've always been like,
oh, your persona on
"The Daily Show" is so--
and the thing is, I
can't think about it.
If I become aware of that,
then I am dead in the water.
Because for me, I just go out
there and try to be funny,
and communicate, and try to hit
the jokes, and do the thing.
And my persona is something that
just has developed organically
over time.
I think all of that, all
of the correspondents
have their very
specific persona.
But it comes, hopefully,
out of an organic process.
And it took a while
for it to evolve.
But I don't try to think
about it that much.
Because otherwise, it
will go away or something.
So I don't worry about it.
MALE SPEAKER: Interesting.
I have many favorites, in
terms of scenes from your show.
And you've got a
couple that you've
made quite a mark on the world
at large, in terms of influence
that your work has
actually had on the people
outside of "The Daily Show,"
and thinking specifically
of the politician
from North Carolina--
AASIF MANDVI: Oh right, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: --where you may
have just let him say things.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: What
was that interview?
AASIF MANDVI: That has become
my most famous interview now.
And it was primarily
because-- we do interviews
like that a lot.
And people say crazy
things all the time.
I think what happened
in this instance was,
here was a GOP guy in
North Carolina saying
the N-word and other things
on national television
at the same time as the
GOP was trying to reach out
to African American voters
in that same county.
So what was sad about it
was the GOP fired him.
But it almost felt
like they fired him
because they were like, listen.
You're not allowed
to say that out loud.
We are trying to get
black people to vote.
But it was like that.
But anyway, once he got fired,
then it became national news.
And Rachel Maddow, and CNN,
everyone was talking about it.
But that was one of
those situations where
you don't realize the impact.
You never know.
You just basically
go in there, and let
people-- Stephen Colbert, again.
I go back to Stephen Colbert,
because he said to me
when I first
started at the show.
He said, when you put a
camera in someone's face,
they get a lobotomy.
And you want to take advantage
of that as much as you can.
And the other thing
is, use the silence.
When you don't speak, they
will continue to speak,
and they will fill the silence.
And eventually, they will
do the thing which I call,
I fucked the chicken moment.
They will say, I
fucked the chicken.
And once they say, I fucked the
chicken, you have your piece.
That's it.
Then you can just be like--
(MUMBLING) I think we're done.
We're good here.
Oh, we've got everything.
You pretty much
fucked the chicken?
Yeah, I fucked the chicken.
So sometimes it
takes a long time
to get to the I fucked
the chicken moment.
And sometimes, they say, I
fucked the chicken right away.
But eventually, hopefully,
if the piece goes well, they
will say, I fucked the chicken.
I'm just going to see
how many times I can say,
I fucked the chicken.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that
at all a reference
to Jon's favorite news clip he'd
picked up where someone's like,
keep fucking that chicken.
AASIF MANDVI: Keep
fucking that chicken.
Yeah.
And it is exactly that.
It is like, when
they say that thing
that they or their lawyers
wish they had never said
is when you have the piece.
And that's what happened with
Don Yelton, where he basically
started on this whole, oh,
I'm making fun of Obama.
He had a cartoon of
Obama as a witch doctor,
and he said he was making
fun of Obama's white half.
Which first, didn't
even make any sense.
And so once he
went on that roll,
I knew that I just had
to stay out of the way.
Now, my job was not to
encourage or discourage.
It was just to step
back and let him go.
And that's what happened,
and sometimes those things
work out really well.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So do you have any
personal favorites
that you look back on?
Clips that you were just--
AASIF MANDVI: I do.
That one is obviously
a favorite of mine.
I also loved the time
I asked Governor Rick
Scott to pee in a cup.
We were doing a
piece down in Florida
about mandatory drug testing
for people on welfare.
It was a valid piece.
But what was great
about it was, Rick Scott
was having a press conference
to announce his budget
for the upcoming year.
And we thought it
would be great.
Because what we realized is that
like, a lot of these people who
are advocating this
law, their reasoning
was that welfare
is taxpayer money.
And therefore, the
taxpayer should
know where that money is going.
And so these people
should be drug tested.
But surprise, surprise.
The people who
are also lawmakers
in the state of Florida are
getting paid by the taxpayer.
And so why should they not
be drug tested, as well?
So this was our premise
that we went in with,
and we thought we would
take it to the highest
level in Florida, which
is the governor himself.
And so we interrupted a
press conference of his
with about as many
journalists as there
are sitting in this
room right now,
and asked him if he would
give us a urine sample.
And I had the cup right there.
I said, you can do it right now.
We'll all turn around.
You could just give
us a quick sample.
And he was not happy about that.
I think at first, he
was trying to be polite.
But eventually, he
was like, I'm running
this press conference,
not you, OK?
Sit down.
And so even though he
got mad and shut us up,
we had the moment.
And what was great about it was,
when it aired-- first of all,
before it aired-- because
every media outlet in Florida
was in that room.
Meanwhile, none of them made a
sound while I was doing this.
They were just
gobsmacked and sat there,
afraid to laugh,
afraid to do anything.
Because they want to
get in that room again,
and I don't give a shit.
You know what I mean?
So they're all like, we want to
be invited to this party again.
We are not going to
make fun of the host.
So they all sat there.
But the minute we walked
out, they came upon us.
And they were literally
like, that was amazing.
We wish we could do that.
And then it was in all
the Florida newspapers,
it was on all the local news.
And my parents, who live
in Tampa, of course,
my dad calls me.
And he just answered the phone.
I'm like, what?
He's like, what did you do?
And he had heard it on the
radio and on the local news.
And then when the piece aired,
I realized how much Floridians
hate Rick Scott, and they
were so happy that happened.
So that's one of my
personal favorites as well.
MALE SPEAKER: That's hilarious.
OK.
Well, we are at the
top of the hour.
Since we started
a little late, I
wanted to give us a few
minutes for questions.
AASIF MANDVI: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Of
course, Aasif's going
to want to get lunch after this.
We've got a book signing.
Make sure you grab a book.
I think they take credit card,
perhaps even Google Wallet.
Who knows?
So we didn't have--
AASIF MANDVI: You're putting
$10 with a credit card?
Just, come on.
You just give him the $10.
MALE SPEAKER: So any
questions from the audience?
AASIF MANDVI: Yeah.
Right here.
MALE SPEAKER: Repeat
the question for--
AASIF MANDVI: Ah, yes.
So she said, why do people
agree to do interviews
when they are going to get,
I think you used the term,
"hosed?"
I think people
have things to say.
People are passionate
about what they believe.
And, look.
Sometimes, we're
talking to people
that no one else is
willing to talk to.
Let's face it.
But sometimes, I think it's
honestly that people really
do feel passionately
about certain things.
And going back to
the Don Yelton thing,
I don't think he realized
that he was being racist.
I think he thought he was
being honest and revealing
some real honesty
about the whole thing,
not realizing that he was
coming off as a complete racist.
And so I think
people don't always
realize how the
thoughts in their head
sound when they come
out of their mouth.
And I talked to a woman once
who tried to convince me
that one in five
Muslims was a terrorist.
And then she said, do the math.
And so I did.
And it would make about
500 million terrorists.
And I thought to
myself, why the fuck
has it taken us so long then?
If we have that many
people working for us?
Jesus, we are the worst!
But things like that.
And then she was amazed
that she was getting threats
from people when
that piece aired.
And not from Muslims, from
like liberal white people who
were like, you can't say that.
That's just not true.
So I think people just
don't realize sometimes.
Yeah?
How the work?
Well, I think theater is a great
grounding, base level education
in terms of acting
and [INAUDIBLE] now.
Even in "The Daily Show."
For example, people always
think, oh, Aasif Mandvi--
you're just yourself
on "The Daily Show."
But I'm actually not myself.
I consider myself
playing a character who
happens to have my
name, and a whole team
of Jewish writers who can
travel with him wherever he goes
and a greenscreen that
he walks around with.
But the thing is that it
was a great education.
Theater was a great
place to start.
Because if you
can do theater, it
teaches you everything about how
to be on television and film.
You can't always
do the other way.
You see film actors or TV
actors trying to do theater,
and they fail.
But from theater to
television, I think often,
it gives you the tools.
And playwriting, just in
terms of how a scene can work,
and what makes.
And it's great.
Because on the brink, I'm
actually a co-producer
and a writer on
the show, as well.
And so it's been
really great to be
able to work with those
writers on a TV show.
And a lot of those guys
are playwrights as well,
who have transitioned
into television writing.
In fact, a lot of the
great television writers
today started as playwrights.
Lewis Black started
as a playwright.
Not a lot of you knew that.
That's one to grow on.
There you go.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is this working?
Hello?
Yes?
OK.
So I had a question
about "The Internship."
I was actually a
Google intern, and I
want to say that it's
wildly inaccurate.
AASIF MANDVI: Good, good, good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And I
was wondering how--
AASIF MANDVI: I didn't
write it, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Has that
changed your opinion?
Like being here today
also, how has that
affected your opinion of
what Google is, and did
you like think of
it differently?
AASIF MANDVI: I don't see
anybody doing a lick of work
on this campus.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
AASIF MANDVI: Here's
what I've seen.
I've seen volleyball.
I've seen people stuffing
their faces with food.
Everyone's got a takeout
container, wherever they go.
And I've seen people just
riding their bicycles.
It's like a daycamp.
It's like a retreat.
AUDIENCE: It's like a
playground for adults.
AASIF MANDVI: It is, yes.
I have not seen one
person coding, nowhere.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, you told
him to shut his computer.
AASIF MANDVI: Of course,
the one overachieving Indian
is like, I was coding!
I've been coding all day!
You were on Facebook.
You were tweeting, I'm sitting
in [INAUDIBLE] right now.
No.
But what did you say?
Has it changed my opinion?
Not one iota, no.
It was a movie.
And so obviously, there
were wild inaccuracies
needed in it to tell the story.
But did you guys all
have to watch the movie?
Was it a mandatory thing?
They were like,
now, we will again,
have our next screening
of, "The Internship."
You will get an F for the
semester if you don't watch it.
AUDIENCE: So you had said
that when you came to the UK,
you obviously were not
treated equally like others.
Did you feel like you
became equal at some point?
Or did you have to come to
America for you to feel equal?
AASIF MANDVI: Did I
feel like I became
equal when I got to America?
You haven't been in America
very long, have you?
Look-- from my perspective,
there is much more
representation of South
Asians in the media,
and on television, and
in general out there.
Do we still have a long
way to go in terms of that?
Yeah.
Look, at the end of the
day, Hollywood still
prefers white people.
They're easier to
light, apparently.
You don't need all
those gobos and things.
But look, we are a technological
milestone in the history,
and this place is
full of Indian people.
So I consider that a
little bit of a victory.
AUDIENCE: I don't
mean as a group.
AASIF MANDVI: Right,
you mean personal.
AUDIENCE: I mean you.
AASIF MANDVI: Here's what I did.
I got on TV, and then that
is the great equalizer
in terms of having a platform
to be able to say things.
Even the fact that you guys are
listening to me talk right now.
But in a larger
cultural context,
do I still deal with racism,
and all of that stuff?
Yes, absolutely.
But I think,
hopefully, now what I
do is, I just show them
my "Daily Show" card
and get right through security.
Yes, right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm also a child
of immigrants.
AASIF MANDVI: Yes, good.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Trinidadian
immigrants.
So West Indian, not East Indian.
AASIF MANDVI: Well, "The Mystic
Masseur" was set in Trinidad.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Naipaul.
AASIF MANDVI: And I
had to do a Trinidadian
accent for that movie.
AUDIENCE: Did you?
AASIF MANDVI: Do you
do a Trini accent?
AUDIENCE: See, don't
put me on the spot.
AASIF MANDVI: Come on.
AUDIENCE: I can't do it.
AASIF MANDVI: I'll do
mine if you do yours.
AUDIENCE: I can't do that.
I can't do it.
AASIF MANDVI: (TRINI
ACCENT) Ya don't
like to do that Trini accent?
No?
Come on!
AUDIENCE: (TRINI
ACCENT) Oh, well now.
AASIF MANDVI: (TRINI
ACCENT) Oh, now.
AUDIENCE: OK, OK.
I see it.
AASIF MANDVI:
(TRINI ACCENT) Never
call, you never call to
say, cat, how you is dog?
AUDIENCE: (TRINI
ACCENT) You can't
do a Trini accent like me.
AASIF MANDVI: Nice, nice.
AUDIENCE: And I also
moved around a lot
once I moved to America.
So I was wondering,
did you ever reconcile
all of those different
pieces and parts of yourself
into one single identity?
Or do you still think
of it as, well, there
are just multiple
parts to my identity.
AASIF MANDVI: I think
the multiplicity becomes
the source of where your
creativity comes from,
where your power comes from,
where all of that stuff
comes from.
I'm jealous of people
who are one thing
and can identify with
that one thing as them.
I've never felt that.
So the multiplicity
and the shapeshifting
has always been my source
of power and creativity.
So it took me a
long time to realize
that was a positive,
and not a negative.
But once I got there, I realize
that now, that is what I do.
Good question, good question.
See now, those are the kinds
of questions we're looking for.
No, I'm kidding.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: There's
time for one more.
AASIF MANDVI: Right there.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
what your thoughts were
on colorblind casting.
I know that "Grey's Anatomy's"
a show that they've mentioned.
It's a thing I was
wondering if you
think it's the
future of casting.
AASIF MANDVI:
Colorblind casting?
Like you mean anybody, any
ethnicity can play any role?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
so they don't have
a typical look
for the character.
AASIF MANDVI: Listen, that is, I
think, the tapestry of America.
I don't think we're
going to get to a place
where we will have-- unless,
maybe they could probably
do it if they were adopted.
I was going to say, brown
parents with white kids.
But you could do that
in a certain scenario.
But I think in terms of,
there are roles out there
that anybody can
play, in terms of,
it doesn't matter what
ethnicity you are?
I don't think we are there yet.
But there are still more
roles for white people
than anybody else.
And there's always that one
role for the brown person.
I was just having this
conversation earlier today
with someone where
it was like, there's
one role for a brown person
and 50 roles for white people.
So that still exists.
And hopefully, that will change.
And Shonda Rhimes is
someone who is actually
pushing the boundaries of
that, pushing the envelope.
And this is why
I've always said,
we need more ethnic, or at
least minority immigrant,
whatever you want to call it--
writers, producers, creators
out there, and people who are
shaping the culture in the way
that Google is.
Because ultimately, those
things get reflected back
into the media and into the
larger society as a whole.
Let's face it;
one of the reasons
I was cast in "The Internship"
as the head of the Google
intern program, and
I'm South Asian,
is because you guys
are here at Google.
And so that representation
needs to be shown.
If that movie had been
made 20 years ago,
there would have been no Google.
But if it was a
movie like that, it
would've been a white
guy in that role playing
the boss, as it were.
So I think that, for me,
personally, was something
that I benefited from
in terms of the larger
cultural visibility.
MALE SPEAKER: A great
message to end on.
We are out of time.
But we do have a book signing--
AASIF MANDVI: We do.
MALE SPEAKER: --for
"No Land's Man."
AASIF MANDVI: "No Land's Man."
MALE SPEAKER: I think it's going
on sale within a couple days.
We've got some early
advanced copies.
AASIF MANDVI: You've got
some advanced copies.
It actually goes officially
on sale on November 4th.
If you don't get one
today, you can preorder it
on wherever preorders happen.
MALE SPEAKER: And then when
does "The Brink" come out
next season?
AASIF MANDVI: "The Brink"
comes out next year.
MALE SPEAKER: Next year?
AASIF MANDVI: Yes.
So they'll all be
on HBO next year.
And then I'll be back on
"The Daily Show" this fall.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's hear
it for Aasif Mandvi.
AASIF MANDVI: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]